And now the old scoutmaster.
Horace Kappart was a very well-known author
and you may have even seen some of his books,
even though he wrote them almost a century ago now.
One of them is Woodcraft and Camping.
He wrote it in 1916..
And just to show that the more things change,
the more they remain the same,
Let me read you this passage.
I do this as regularly as the birds come back in the spring,
And their kind has been doing it since the world began.
It's good for us
If some misguided genius should invent a camping equipment
that nobody could find fault with.
half our pleasure in life would be swept away.
Oh, it's still true today.
Yep, we have to have gear
and then we get to mess around with it and read about it.
I'm pretty sure that's the only reason we go camping,
Just so we can have this.
Oh well,
This is podcast number 147..
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
Not real full this week, but we heard from a couple of people.
Jono wrote in
And Jono's last name.
I'm going to give it a shot. Jono,
Tell me how I do.
How about that?
Get in touch. okay,
If I really murdered it. get in touch with me.
But Jono wrote in and said very simply:
thanks for all your podcasts and work,
Much appreciated in Northern California.
Well, we certainly appreciate hearing from you,
And I also received this comment on the blog.
While I typically enjoy the thought-provoking articles,
they seem to have taken on a commercial nature recently.
That is a very astute observation
And, yes, due to the season,
some of the blog articles are a bit more commercial in nature
than normally,
And I don't think we've ever really talked about this on the
podcast before. but let's talk about the assorted financial
details of being a blogger and a podcaster.
I really enjoy writing and I enjoy speaking to you on the
podcast and it's all great fun.
It takes a lot of time.
It takes a tremendous amount of time
And it also costs a little bit of money-
Not tremendous amounts of money, but a little bit of money.
So I use two commonly available of creating a little financial
revenue to offset the time and the money I spend in creating
the blog and the podcast.
These two things are affiliate marketing and online advertising.
Affiliate marketing, in a nutshell, is: if you're a blog
or a podcaster, you associate yourselves with
different vendors,
You provide links to the goods or services that they
offer. when someone buys one of those goods or services,
you get a commission
And usually that commission is somewhere south of 10%.
More often than not it's about 5% to 7%.
So let's say you see a product reviewed or featured on the
blog and you click on an affiliate link and you buy
that product.
I'm going to get a small commission on that.
When I review a product or service online and I suggest
it to you for purchase is almost always going to be
something that I have personally used and a lot of times
for a good many years, and I can hardly recommend to you.
Sometimes people get in touch with me and they offer me
things to review.
Sometimes I get in touch with them if I think
something might be particularly useful or applicable to
the way that scouts camp and hike and things like that.
All the gear and equipment you see on the blog that
I talk about where there is a link to a place to buy it is
going to earn me a very small commission.
You also, if you visit the blog at scoutmastercgcom,
you'll see some advertising
And if you click on those ads I get a small fee for every
click that happens on those ads.
I have very limited editorial control over what appears
in those ads,
So don't consider them to be products I've endorsed or
used or reviewed.
But I thought we would just draw back the curtain a moment.
look into the realities of doing this.
So the revenue from things like that on the blog amount to
not much.
It pays for the different services that I have to engage to
keep the blog online and to publish the podcast.
It pays for some of the equipment involved-
I mean, there's microphones and stuff like that that
you need-
And on occasion there's enough of a surplus to
compensate me in a very small way for some of the time
I spend provoking your thoughts.
So so in this podcast we're going to in scout
master ship in seven minutes or less, continue with our
series on four steps to scout advancement.
Last time we had the introduction, this time
step number one,
And then I have a couple of email questions and
answers to share with you.
So let's get started. shall we scout master ship in
seven minutes or less?
Last week we introduced this series about the four
steps to scout advancement,
And last time around we contextualize advancement
within all the aims and methods.
This week we're going to talk about step one, and
that is that a scout learns.
Now the subsequent steps are: step two, a scout is
tested. step three, a scout is reviewed. and step
four, a scout is recognized.
So how does learning happen in the context of
scouting?
Well, let me read you this quote from Albert Einstein.
He said this: it is in fact nothing short of a
miracle that the modern methods of instruction
have not entirely strangled the Holy Spirit of
Inquiry,
For this delicate little plan, aside from
stimulation, stands mainly in need of freedom.
Without this, it goes to rack and ruin without
fail.
It can be a very grave mistake to think that the
enjoyment of seeing and searching can be
promoted by means of coercion and a sense of
duty.
And in the Scout Master's Handbook we read
this: learning is a natural outcome of
scouting activities.
Instruction in scout skills can come from a
number of sources.
Most important are the scouts themselves,
sharing what they know with one another and
helping each other along the advancement trail.
So when we introduce this idea of learning
into the context of scouting, we usually
think of the more common academic model of
learning,
And I identify that model this way:
The students are passive, the teachers are
active and the attainment of a certain
standard of performance is paramount,
And we need to understand that scouting
is not an academic exercise in that sense,
And that's the key,
That's what I really want to get across to you-
We can say scouting is not school, and that
is half the message.
But what we really want to think about is
that scouting focuses on what Einstein calls
that Holy Spirit of Inquiry.
Learning in scouting is experiential,
a process of discovery.
It's not an academic exercise.
Learning is the natural outcome
of scout activities.
We don't put the cart before the horse here.
We do what scouts do and they learn
as a result of doing that.
And so there's this kind of subtle emphasis
that I think we find lacking in a lot of places,
that we start with learning stuff
and the activities just kind of follow in suit.
Well, it's totally the other way around.
We start with doing what scouts do
and they learn as a result.
And this process of discovery
is one question following another,
just like a path of breadcrumbs,
until scouts discover what they need to know.
So what's the practical purpose
in learning to tie a square knot?
Well, it joins two ropes together.
What does a scout gain
from learning to tie a square knot?
On the surface, he learns to join two ropes together
And that's a great practical skill.
But simply learning that practical skill
isn't the point.
Our aim is the process of discovery
that enables scouts to lead themselves,
and subsequently others,
to learning anything that they need to know.
Self-leadership is the first step
in leadership development.
You learn to lead yourself
and then you're able to lead others.
Scouts discover these things
in the course of doing what scouts do,
and then they master them
and they begin to share them with their fellow scouts.
That's the focus of what scouting is
and how it's different from that academic model.
Now, anybody can teach a scout
to tie a square knot in a few minutes,
Left over right, right over left.
Now you try it.
The scout's passive,
I'm active,
He watches,
Then he tries.
It's an echo of what he's done in school
a thousand times:
Listen to the teacher,
Do what the teacher does.
This is efficient,
This is effective,
But I'm going to contend
that it's not really scouting.
Whenever possible-
and it's almost always possible-
we initiate this process of discovery
In the course of a camping trip.
a scout needs to tie two ropes together.
How does he make that happen?
Well, does he have a scout handbook?
Can he find out how to do this
by looking in the handbook.
Can he find the right page?
What does it say there?
Can you learn how to do this?
Yes, I can.
Can you show it to somebody else?
A whole other field of inquiry opens up
when we ask other questions.
What does a square knot symbolize in scouting?
When would you use a square knot?
You'd probably use it twice a day
at a minimum to tie your shoes.
What? That's not a square knot?
Are you sure?
Can you see a square knot in there?
One question follows another,
building on this spirit of independent inquiry,
this spirit of discovery,
And pretty soon
we're out of the picture all together,
because the scout knows how to find things out.
Learning skills in scouting
is kind of like a head fake in basketball.
Do you know what a head fake is?
That's when a player fakes you out
by looking in one direction
and moving in another direction.
In scouting, it looks like
what we want to do
is just learn some practical knowledge and skills,
but we're really off in another direction.
Learning how to learn
is what we're looking for.
A skill that far surpasses the simple knowledge
of joining those two ropes together
is the skill of learning how to learn.
As scouts gain these practical skills,
they begin to instruct and lead others,
and then we start to reap the other benefits
of this discovery process.
Discovery is not as linear and efficient
as the academic method,
but what does it create?
At an Eagle border review,
what's more important to you?
A scout who remembers how to tie a square knot
or a scout who's capable of leading himself
and others to discover
and accomplish nearly anything?
Ideally, scouts gain achievement towards advancement
as a natural outcome of what they're doing
in their patrol or troop.
We don't do requirements,
We do what scouts do.
And what do scouts do?
They go camping and hiking,
They build a fire,
They cook over a fire,
They build towers and bridges,
They play games.
If scouts are doing what scouts do,
they will be completing requirements.
I for sure learned the hard way
that nothing drains the spontaneous joy
and excitement out of scouting
More than telling scouts something like
you know now, fellas,
we're going to work on requirements.
They have to put down the fun,
intriguing, interesting things they're doing
and stand around listening to somebody
tell them how to do requirements.
So the way a scout learns
and the place of learning in scouting
creates useful, even important, life skills,
But those skills are nothing more
than a means to a greater end,
And that is developing a capable,
contributing, decent human being.
We work towards this by inspiring
what Einstein called
that Holy Spirit of Inquiry
and desire for achievement.
that is measured by the effort
that a scout extends,
not just by the sum of his performance,
And we're going to look closely at
step number two. a scout is tested
in our next podcast.
Oh, I'm in love with the man who loves to camp.
He camps when it's sunny,
He camps when it's damp.
All he needs is a tent, a sleeping roll,
a package of hot dogs and a sack of charcoal.
He camps in the desert,
He camps in the snow.
He says: baby, come with me,
A snowman,
Write me a letter,
Send it by name.
Email, that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your
emails.
I received two emails since the last podcast
that basically had the same kind of question,
So I'm kind of mixing those two emails together.
On a recent camping weekend
the boys did not help with cooking,
clean up and washing dishes
as much as they should have.
They would begin their tour
but then begin to vanish to other places
to have fun.
So when they woke up Sunday morning
looking for a hot breakfast of eggs.
the adult leaders said it was not happening
because griddles did not get cleaned
the prior night.
They also littered the campsite with
wrappers the night before.
Of course, the next morning
they cleaned up the site,
but that's not the point.
In the past,
adults have done all the cooking on trips.
What suggestions do you have
for working this out
and keeping the boys accountable and responsible?
Our troop is a good troop,
but they're primarily adult-led,
not patrol-led.
I realize Rome wasn't built in today,
so how can they begin to teach
the boys what they should have been doing
all along?
What do you do about a situation
when boys vanish
when there's work to be done?
How do you start out teaching
clueless boys how to cook and wash dishes?
I think that adults
need to model what is required
and work with them,
teach them and direct them.
We have a great group of adults
and the troop has approximately 30 boys
and the majority of them are on the younger side.
Thanks for any thoughts you may have about this.
The situation you describe
is not all that uncommon
and its cause is
adults running the troop,
Plain and simple.
So I want to get you started thinking
about a few basic ideas.
First,
scouting is something
that scouts do for themselves,
not something that adults
present to them.
Second,
scouts can do everything
for themselves
Other than, you know,
a very few administrative functions.
Scouts can make menus
and purchase food and cook for
and clean up after themselves.
They can plan their activities,
instruct and prepare those fellow scouts
to participate in them.
They can lead their fellow scouts through activities
and help their fellow scouts advance and rank.
The adult role in scouting
is helping scouts discover
their leadership abilities
and helping scouts find the resources
that they need and getting out of the way
so that they can do it.
Let me tell you about my weekend,
and I'm telling you about it
just to contrast what you've described.
Well, I'm really proud of my scouts.
They're not super humans or anything like that.
They're just like your scouts,
And last weekend we went backpacking with them.
We had 17 scouts with a pretty good distribution
of ages from 11 to 16,
and we had nine adults along-
a lot for us on any given weekend,
But we've got a lot of guys
who really like to go backpacking.
The adult role on this outing
was basically chartering the bus
that took us there,
helping the patrol leadership council
determine what route they would follow
and accompanying the scouts on the trip.
Everything else
was done by the scouts.
They planned their meetings to prepare themselves
for backpacking,
with instruction on the proper gear
and food that they'd need and things like that,
And adults did know
not even a minute's worth of instruction.
Everything done in those meetings
was done by the boys.
Each patrol planned their meals,
purchased and packed their food,
prepared it and cleaned up after themselves.
No adult touched a pot or a pan
or a stove
or any of the food the scouts brought.
We cooked for ourselves.
We got there Friday night
and the scouts had a campsite
from the adults.
They set up their own tents.
They camped and hiked
the whole weekend as patrols,
each patrol staying together.
For the most part the scouts hiked
well in front of the adult group.
No adults hiked with the scouts
because the scouts
looked after themselves.
We observed and advised
only if we were asked
or if a decision on part of the scouts
would lead to some kind of you know
situation, which, by the way,
wasn't really necessary. on that weekend
I spoke to the senior patrol leader
for perhaps a total of 20 minutes
for the whole weekend,
mostly to check in and to review what was going on.
So how did things go?
Well, I could have solved some problems
for them, but they figured things out in the end.
They did not do everything
perfectly, nor did they do everything
the way that I would have done them
or any of the other adults on the outing
would have done them.
The important was they did it
for themselves.
Every once in a while,
something untoward happens,
But the scouts have elected
patrol leaders and a senior patrol leader
who are responsible for seeing that things go well.
They've learned to ask us
when they need help with these things.
You asked a question that I get asked a lot.
How do you hold scouts accountable
and responsible? Because they're doing
things for themselves. they're always busy,
So they don't disappear when
things to be done, because they're the only ones
who are going to do them.
We don't worry about making them responsible
or holding them accountable to anything,
because they're actually responsible
and accountable to themselves.
If they don't do it, it doesn't get done,
And since the program is something
that they do for themselves,
they're not waiting on some adult
to tell them what to do next.
This is a reasonably good
explanation of the patrol method.
Boys form themselves into patrols,
select their leaders. We work with
those leaders to help them discover
their abilities and talents
and get them the resources that they need,
And then we're off camping.
Now can this happen with a really young troop?
Well, yes, it certainly can.
It'll take a while to develop,
But the backpacking weekend I just described to you-
it can happen. There's no way
to apply this whole patrol method idea
a little bit. It takes
full commitment from all the adults involved
And when it comes down to the very
practical aspects and mechanics of this,
I have little idea of how my scouts do dishes.
They've been
instructed on how to do that, They have the right equipment
for it And once on a blue moon
I'll stroll through a patrol campsite and check on dishes
just to see how things are going.
And he concerns I may have
get handed to the senior patrol leader
and he's going to take them
to the patrol leader. As for
duty rosters and things
like that, it's really none of my business.
I'm pretty sure our scouts
don't use duty rosters
or plans. They just sort of all
pitch in. I honestly don't get involved
with that sort of thing. It's a scout decision.
I mean, there are general expectations
and so long as their decisions are in bounds
of those expectations. I really don't
have a whole lot of concern over the details.
So scouting is not something that
a bunch of good natured adults present
to a group of boys. This is
something that boys do for themselves
When they're actually responsible
and accountable for what they do.
you don't have to hold them responsible
and accountable. The only real limitation
is your understanding
and application of the patrol system.
Well, I hope that helps a little bit
and I really appreciate you for getting in
touch, and you're going to find out
how you can get in touch
in just a moment.
Well, thank you so much
for listening to this edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch.
Just like I promised,
read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom.
While you're there, you can
subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by
signing up.
Thank you so much for listening
to this edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch.
You can also subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email.
The Scoutmaster podcast is available on iTunes
and it's also available
for any mobile device through Stitcher
Smart Radio. You can get details
about how to access that
at stitchercom.
You can experience the wonders of
scoutmastercgcom on the vast
panorama of social media
outlets. Follow us at
scoutmasterblog on Facebook, tweet
scoutmastercg on Twitter
and submit to the exclusive
Scoutmaster CG Circle.
Search for Scoutmaster CG
on Google+.
Please do email me, Clark Green,
your comments and questions
and wild ideas.
You can reach me at
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
The Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America. It's just me.
I got a microphone and a laptop
and a little free time And we're always
trying to help our fellow volunteers
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
Speaking of fun, here he is
our founder, Sir Robert Biddenpal. Sir Robert,
Good luck to you
and group camping
Why? thank you, sir, Until next time.